Jason can you tell us how you booked
your first paid acting job that would be
the secret life of the american teenager
it was when my dad was in the show and
brenda hampton who created it she asked
my dad do you have any kids do they act
and he said yes my son acts and she says
well would he like to be on the show he
says well I mean you'd like that but I
don't want you to just give him apart I
want you to see him so she invited me to
the table read and I read for this part
Joe Hampton nice little last name there
and she liked me and so she brought me
on and so the casting was in LA or New
York it was in Los Angeles I didn't live
in New York until after college okay and
you were what 16 when this yeah I think
I was i think it was 16 i think it was
near the end of my sophomore year so you
were attending high school mm-hmm and um
how did that work but I mean it was how
many episodes were you in that you had
to miss school or maybe didn't miss
school I think I did about I think I did
like 12 episodes total and that was over
the course of a few years he wasn't a
recurring recurring character he'd pop
up every now and again like a little
cameo and I never had to shoot more than
one or two days so if I did miss a day
of school it would just be one day okay
how did that feel to be paid as an actor
because so many actors talk about they
get to a point where they love doing the
work they don't mind doing free work but
after a while they really feel like it's
time that I'm paid well it felt pretty
good because i hadn't i had i was still
in high school so I hadn't really been
doing the whole audition grind or
anything like that I just been in school
plays and local theater and so I didn't
know the feeling of doing 50 auditions
without getting anything and so it felt
nice it felt nice to be on a set I
thought it was educational to see what
it's like and get a feeling for the air
it also made me realize that a hell of a
lot of work to do you know because they
really do have to be on your game when
you're doing a professional set so what
was that first day like like what was
your call time and
then what was I surely make 630 630 ok
and you remember how you felt like
walking on set that day I felt good i
felt cautious i just i was trying to see
what this was because I loved film and
TV sup month so much will mostly film
and so I i was i was once set and i
thought well this is it this is this is
how you do it you know it's not just
like a play or you just get to kind of
do a lot of work by yourself and just
work with people in a small space like
it just i figured out very quickly that
people are there just to do a job they
know what they're going to do is an
actor you show up when a lot of the work
has already been done and you're giving
a call and you just got to show up and
deliver right then and at least as it
especially the day player maybe if
you're a lead you get a little bit more
pre-production time but as a day player
you just show up right so you had not
attended lamba yet of course because
you're in high school so then with the
blocking what was that like I'm not too
familiar with blocking so can you tell
me walking yeah yeah well it's just
there weren't a lot of complicated shots
it would just me be standing in a hall
talking to people in the school hall so
you know the cameras you're trying to
get a certain shot and you gotta be and
the cinematographers already work for
the director to figure out the framing
so they have these marks on the ground
like this tape you got to find your mark
for a certain line or a certain segment
of the action and you got to hit that
mark while doing what you need to do
like whether you're delivering a liar
performing an action like a physical
action and you got to hit it and but
still make it spontaneous and you have
it have intention in that moment without
making it look rehearse so do you
remember when it was your scene and they
called action like how much did you feel
in the moment how scary was it or
exhilarating uh it was exciting and a
little scary yeah I would imagine uh I
mean it was a lot of fun to do was a fun
show
Owen the people and they were really
nice I don't know if I was fully
comfortable yet to be fully present I
had tried but I think it's it takes a
lot to get out of your head and get into
your body it takes a lot of confidence
right so were you cognizant of that at
that time that that there was such a
thing as being present as an actor or
mean at 16 yeah something you were aware
of her I was aware of it I don't know
what it I don't think I knew how it felt
fully it's hard to do it because as a
young actor you see all these grades and
you see the result of the performances
and you want so badly to to have that
result and be that great and the funny
thing is is like when you try to make
that result happens happen that's
usually what makes you tense and not in
the moment right and so ye it takes I
think it takes a while for certain
people to learn that you just gotta let
go and I mean you gotta do your
preparation in order to let go you can't
just walk up and improvise so you got to
really know what you're doing and in the
essence of your character and and and
kind of yourself and the actions but
you